hello everyone
my name is tal arbel i'm a professor in
the department of electrical and
computer
engineering at mcgill university and i'm
a miele canadian cfar ai chair
today i'm going to talk to you a little
bit about some work that's being
conducted in my research team
in my research group called machine
learning for medical image analysis and
i'll tell you
a bit about some of the research that
we've done over time
and some of the students who led this
research
can be found at the bottom of the screen
um
so uh i think everything that i'm going
to be talking about today is very much
in line with the rest of the talks
that were presented earlier
so again this is uh research this is my
research team
past and present i just want to
acknowledge the subset of my
collaborators which are
directly related to this research dr
arnold who will speak
shortly uh join a pre-cup from mcgill
mila in deepmind tal hastner
from facebook ai and yaron gal who works
on uncertainty with us from oxford
so as we know um machine learning and
medical imaging has the potential to
make
huge advances in medicine and in health
care
assisting in things like patient
diagnosis so here's an example
of diagnosing breast cancer
understanding disease development so for
example here's an image of a normal
brain and one
with alzheimer's disease predicting
patient outcome
from images so for example here's an
image of patient of
patients with specific cancers and the
prediction
are things like survival time speeding
up and making accurate clinical trials
for new treatments so that's something
that we're going to specifically be
speaking about today
on the right you can see a brain tumor
of a patient both the t1 contrast mri
and the diffusion weighted imaging and
you can see that with treatment the
brain tumor is shrinking and the patient
is responding to treatment
and permitting advances in personalized
medicine one of the themes of today
so this is things like supposing the
computer will predict that
um this person's uh brain will not
change
over time this could be conveyed to a
clinician the clinician
can then note and say okay the computer
thinks this patient will be stable for
the next year
and then make a personalized medical
decision
so as we know there's been a huge amount
of work uh and successful work
in adapting and developing machine
learning frameworks for
a variety of uh problems in medical
imaging from segmentation to prediction
and classification
however the resulting approaches have
not yet been widely integrated into
clinical practice
as we have discussed uh today at great
length so why is that
so there were a lot of um uh ideas
presented earlier
a lot of it in line with what i'm about
to say um
so there are many reasons why not one
reason is that medical imaging borrows a
lot of or adapts a lot of the theory
from the field of computer vision
and medical imaging has very unique
challenges
data are particularly uncertain um and
the problems are
specifically quite hard and a lot of the
techniques that are developed
for computer vision are not um
applicable for the kind of medical
imaging problems that we have
errors uh can be have huge consequences
of integrated into the clinic
and generally if presented to the
clinician
will lead to mistrust by clinicians
and hesitation and adoption of the
methods into the clinic
also we know that machine learning
algorithms are often developed in
computer science or electrical
engineering labs
where there's often little access to
large-scale annotated data needed for
training
and also there's often a disconnect and
and little access to the clinician and
the real clinical needs um
which should be made accessible as the
methods are being developed so as a
result many of the techniques
in the field are based on the
availability of smaller proprietary or
benchmarking data sets what we call
challenges as a result they may not be
robust
to patient or data variability across
different centers and scanners
and a lot of the machine learning
medical imaging community are optimizing
their methods
to win the challenges so they are basing
it on the established metrics of success
and oftentimes those metrics of success
may not be
important for the specific clinical task
of interest
so one example um which i think is
important
uh is is for example uh segmentation in
medical imaging so automatic
segmentation is
is an area of research and medical image
analysis is very very
important for a lot of clinical domains
and
and you can see on the right uh some
traditional computer vision uh
benchmarking data sets for segmentation
on which people are developing methods
so you can see here for example
there's um the the techniques have to
segment an object it's well defined
different from its background you can
use shape and prior information
and in your models and so these
techniques that are popular in computer
vision um
may be uh applicable to things like
healthy
structure segmentation in in medical
imaging for example here you can see
segmentation of
the ventricles in the brain which might
be important uh or or the hippocampus
and so on this might be
um you know doable we have a specific
region of interest that we're looking at
and then we basically can use things
like shape and other priors to help us
it might also be applicable for
segmenting big
large pathological structures in in
images
but there's a large number of contexts
where patients have
multiple unknown number of focal
pathologies or lesions
some examples on the right include
these god lesions which i'll we'll talk
about shortly in multiple sclerosis
white matter hyper intensities brain
tumors and so on
and here the clinical objective is is to
find them all to be able to diagnose and
stage
the disease so really first we want to
detect them and then we want to
delineate the boundaries and these
present
challenges to traditional machine
learning methods for
in computer vision here you can see an
example with breast cancer
and you can see some of the challenges
we often we'd like to find
if there are any indications of breast
cancer we'd like to detect
breast cancer structures you can see
they often look like other
structures that light up in the image
they're hard to find they can be small
it's hard to
leverage prior information
and we don't know if there are any in
this image uh or how many there might be
and so um you can see the challenges
that we have and we're going to talk
today about two specific contexts one in
the context of
multiple sclerosis and the second one in
the context of segmenting
um structures within brain tumors
so the way in which the talk will will
go today is first
we have a short presentation by dr
arnold
who is a neurologist and he'll talk a
little bit about multiple sclerosis and
clinical trial analysis
and the need for precision medicine then
i'll talk a little bit about some work
in my group
on detecting and segmenting lesions and
focal pathologies from patient medical
images
and predicting future disease evolution
which is what we're working on now
and then a phd student in my group
raghav mehta will talk a little bit
about modeling and conveying
uncertainties in deep learning models
and how to propagate uncertainties
across a sequencer of cascaded medical
imaging tests
in order to improve the deep learning
inference and he'll talk specifically
about the context of brain tumor
segmentation and synthesis of missing
mri sequences
and hopefully i'll have a few minutes to
talk about some current work in the lab
and some open challenges so without
further ado
uh very good okay so uh my name is
douglas arnold i'm a neurologist
at the montreal neurological institute
and
of mcgill with
special expertise in mri particularly as
as employed to investigate multiple
sclerosis or ms
i also had an imaging cro that provides
mri services to
pharma for drug development and a
international collaboration to federate
a large mri and clinical database to
facilitate
ai methods aimed to increase efficiency
of early
early stage clinical trials and ms hence
my uh my involvement in this
in this talk so for those of you who may
not be
familiar multiple sclerosis is
a the most common disease
a neurologic disease that affects young
people it's an inflammatory
demyelinating disease it's also
associated with neurodegeneration
and the pathogenesis is shown in the
panel on the right the inflammatory
cells which are in red
attack myelin which is the insulation or
the sheath around myelin
and damage the myelin and and
potentially also the nerve fiber the
axon
that goes that goes travels within that
myelin
if that fiber is sufficiently damaged to
be effectively cut
the distal portion past the cut will
degenerate because it's disconnected
from the cell body
and hence there is a degenerative
component associated with um
with this inflammatory attack on the
myelin
uh it may be that the the axon survives
the acute demyelination and and even
remyelinates
uh but um in in many cases their
the axon does not properly remyelinate
and uh the
the naked axon uh devoid of myelin has a
limited lifespan and will subsequently
uh
undergo premature degeneration resulting
in
in additional a degenerative component
of the disease there are basically two
forms of ms relapsing ms in which
patients have intermittent attacks of
neurologic
impairment followed by variable recovery
which may be full or not
about 10 percent of patients have a
progressive form of ms in which the
relapses
do not appear but they have a
progressive accumulation of
of disability
there's no cure for this disease but
there are uh treatments uh
these can be very effective for uh
suppressing the focal inflammatory
component of the disease that i've just
described to you they're much less
effective
at preventing the degenerative component
of disease
hence there is a major effort being
undertaken to try and develop
better drugs for the the progressive
component of ms
the hallmark of ms is a multifocal
mr lesions on mri which you can see in
the panel on the right
in grayscale and the left image and with
the lesions highlighted in red
on the in the right hand panel
acutely inflamed lesions that are less
than about a month old
are gadolinium enhancing and associated
with new t2 lesion formation
they gather they they enhance with gad
because the inflammation increases the
permeability of the blood-brain barrier
and the contrast can get into these
lesions
after about a month the acute
inflammation will resolve
and again enhancement resolves but a a
t2 lesion or a new t2 lesion is left
behind as a marker of the
of the tissue injury thus the total t
lesion volume is a marker of the burden
of disease related to lesions
the normal appearing tissue is in fact
not
completely normal it's also affected by
the disease it has a component of the
generation associated with it
and some inflammation which is uh of a
different sort that you don't see
with gadolinium but the normal occurring
brain tissue involvement is also
important for
uh for a disease progression and so we
can't ignore it
um this talk is concerned with drug
development and assessment of drug
efficacy and this is usually done
uh in in what are called clinical trials
clinical trials for ms
at the end of their stage and need to
have clinical outcomes to assess their
efficacy primarily
relapses but this outcome is rather
inefficient
it's noisy and does not occur at very
high
frequency and so there is a
a heavy reliance on mri biomarkers of
inflammatory activity
in earlier stages of ms drug development
to allow for much shorter and smaller
trials and in these trials the markers
that we use or the outcome measures that
we use are
usually some measure of new t2 lesion
formation
and some measure of gadolinium enhancing
lesion formation
in the past the somewhat remote past now
these lesions were
identified and segmented manually or
with some
semi-audited computer help this was a
slow
a process that was uh expensive and uh
more importantly inconsistent uh i.e uh
resulting in variable data that
increased the sample size is required to
show
a drug effect and so there was a need
for automated methods for both detection
and segmentation of lesions and as tal
alluded to in our introduction
uh the um the the key to this is not
necessarily the same as
as many many other
computer vision tasks and and methods
for assessing them
are concerned we're interested in
detection primarily
so that we we don't miss a new activity
on the scans
and this uh this detection needs to be
consistent uh
over time it needs to be robust across
multiple scanners because there are many
scanners involved in
clinical trials that needs to be robust
to the different stages
of the disease
um so to assess ms activity we want to
detect
all the lesions even the small ones
which are substantially more challenging
than than the large ones
you can see here um the
number of lesions and the number of
small spots that you're trying to detect
in the field of
of millions of voxels
the visual identification of these
lesions even by
expert radiologists is it is problematic
the agreement is
in fact somewhat disappointingly low
with errors in both directions either
seeing lesions that are in fact not
new or calling lesions new that are not
new or or
missing uh lesions that are fact present
but not new
present and new but not visualized so
the you can
see from this uh the pictures on the
right that the
you know any individual slice can be
associated with very many lesions
you have uh very many slices associated
with every brain image
and for a person to go through these and
not miss a single new bright spot
or or realize that a scan which might be
taken at a slightly different
angle from the comparator scan has a
you know a lesion at the back of one
slice
which is uh on a different slice in the
previous image is is not a trivial task
and there are many errors
in fact when this is done manually um
the the the new t2 lesion counts
basically to integrate activity since
the previous scan
the gat enhancing lesions which i
discussed briefly before are a marker of
more
acute current disease activity the image
on the right
shows an example of gad enhancing lesion
the bright spot
the the the problems with identifying
gut enhancing lesions are shown in the
in the bottom images there are there may
be multiple lesions but there
are many more bright spots in the gadden
hence
images due to enhancement of normal
structures primarily blood vessels
and it is not trivial to uh to
disambiguate
these normal structures from in fact
lesions uh which
which again may be small and not very
not very strongly enhancing
so the um returning a bit to clinical
trials
the development of new treatments for ms
requires uh
usually a global effort with thousands
of scans from hundreds of different
scanners
and so automated methods that are
accurate and precise
are very important but these have to be
very robust
in order to to provide reliable data
from many many scanners
located around the world
my involvement in this effort
most recently has been through a effort
funded by the international progressive
ms alliance the ipmsa
which is devoted towards collecting or
federating a
large number of scans and associated
clinical data from
many clinical trials that have been done
recently in ms
this involves tens of thousands of
patients and
literally thousands of different imaging
centers each with a different scanner
it's a non-trivial challenge as tao will
will describe to you because we have
multiple imaging modalities as you can
see here t1 weighted t2 weighted proton
density weighted flare
at t1 post contrast we have multiple
time points for each person who is
scanned serially
you know at the beginning of the scan of
the trial before they go on the drug
and then at different intervals after
they go on the drug
and um we have for many of these trials
uh expert generated lesion labels for
uh these many thousands of uh of scans
not a task that can be easily
accomplished in an academic uh
setting
uh so uh we've been collaborating with
uh professor uh arbel for years now
to uh develop machine learning methods
to try and automate
these tasks um and um
the uh these this collaboration with
uh with with professor armel and her and
her colleagues
uh has uh resulted in a very major
improvements in our ability to
uh to actually detect and segment the
lesions in these clinical trials this is
uh a significant increase in efficiency
and and most importantly a significant
increase in the accuracy and precision
of the outcome measures that we make
which translates into more efficient
trials greater statistical power you
know less time less patience less money
involved
another thing that we would like to do
relates to precision medicine which has
been discussed
previously we'd like to be able to
predict what's going to happen
in individuals with ms will they have
relapses or mri disease activity will
they suffer from disability progression
and will they respond to a to a
particular
treatment or not
so the prediction of future mri lesion
activity
based on a baseline mri would be
extremely valuable it would offer
uh for one thing a better understanding
of the natural history of the disease
also allow for an automatic assessment
of risk
and appropriate treatment selection
either something
you know highly effective that might be
more dangerous or something
perhaps only moderately effective that
might be safer
it would also allow hopefully for
prediction of treatment efficacy or
treatment response on a
on a drug specific basis
this is currently not possible with the
clinical or the imaging data
that we collect the standard outcome
metrics are i mean they
have some predictive value but it's not
sufficient
um so we're quite uh
quite keen to develop ai methods that
will allow us to
predict future disability
in particular this is important for
trials in progressive
ns because at the moment we don't have a
marker such as new t2 lesion formation
or gad formation that lets us perform
efficient
early stage trials we have to go to
large phase 3 trials which cost hundreds
of millions of dollars
we would like to develop markers for
predicting whether a given treatment is
going to be effective or not
without the before going to these large
trials
and so we need to develop better better
methods hopefully
ai will be able to do this to predict
disability progression and to predict
treatment response
the problem as i alluded is that the
lesions are not well correlated with
disease progression the lesions we can
very effectively suppress
now but our ability to press disease
progression is actually
disappointingly limited
structure volumes are not not sufficient
as i said
but structural changes have to be
associated with uh
progression and so we
we believe that we will be able to find
changes in the mri that we're currently
not seeing or measuring with our
with our current outcomes that will in
fact correlate with
and be able to predict disease
progression and
and treatment response uh
so i'll turn it back over to tal now
thanks very much for your attention
okay great so thank you very much for
that thorough introduction
um okay so with that i'm going to talk
to you
very briefly about some uh work that
we've done in our
group on multiple sclerosis lesion
detection
and segmentation and so
um in the context of clinical trials we
have just
already developed some sort of
probabilistic machine learning
techniques
for detecting and segmenting t2 lesions
um new and enlarging t2 lesions on
longitudinal or sequential mri scans
and gadolinium-enhanced lesions and so
um some of these methods are the methods
that dr arnold alluded to that were
placed into the commercial software
pipeline of our industrial partner
so that they can be used for clinical
trial analysis for pretty much
uh most of our of the new uh drugs
recently approved and used worldwide
so i will not get to too much into the
methods but just to tell you
um we've built probabilistic methods for
all of them which means that
we've included uh and modeled the
uncertainty which is inherent
to all of these problems so we for t2
lesion segmentation and detection we
developed
a probabilistic model that in fact it
is a iterative hierarchical graphical
model for those that know it's a mark
off random field
and the idea is um to basically input
and a sequence of mri images um
we have a graphical model which looks at
the voxels
and uh and their neighbors and infers a
probability of each voxel being a lesion
they're grouped into candidate lesion um
lesions on the image and then a higher
level graphical model takes
relationship to neighboring structures
into account uh probabilistically as
well as
the intensities of the group so the idea
here is that were
designed to be very very sensitive and
to detect all the lesions even the small
ones
and the method was shown to have
significant advantage
particularly for small lesions which
make up a very large
proportion of the lesions in in the
context of clinical trials
we also developed methods um
on segmenting new and resolving lesions
in serial mri as was stated in the
st in the relapsing remitting phase of
the disease um the lesions
um new lesions uh appear and
and grow and other lesions resolve so we
developed
uh completely or partially and we
developed a probabilistic bayesian
machine learning method to sort of
track and detect the evolution of these
new t2 lesions over time so here we have
baseline image here you could see
week 4 week 12 and so on the model
actually
integrates information from the images
at all these time points and sort of
learns probabilistic models for the
kinds of changes that we have in terms
of intensity
um transitions from one class to the
other for example lesions to healthy
tissues
and other things um in a big bayesian
model
and you can see here the result is that
um the system differentiates between
stable lesions here which we can see in
red
resolving or shrinking lesions which we
can see here in blue
and the new uh or enlarging lesions
which appear which
is very helpful in assessing treatment
effects both in the clinic
and in clinical trials and then we also
built the first
probabilistic machine learning framework
this is also a graphical
model a conditional random field to
automatically detect gadolinium-enhanced
ms lesions that very challenging task
which dr arnold referred to
the method also combines both voxel
level and
higher level information to basically
maximally pull apart
um non-legional versus legional
enhancements so these are just some
qualitative results to show you where we
trained on a fairly
big clinical trial with over 2000 scans
from over 200 different centers and we
tested it on two other
big clinical trials you could see here
just want to show you the kind of task
that's involved so here you have the
image
these are three different patient images
and here you could see the image
and in the middle are all of the
enhancements um after you inject the
patient with a contrast agent
and among all of these enhancements the
only one that is actually
due to the disease this gad and lydium
enhanced
lesion is right over here and our method
was able to find
this lesion here is a zoom in of what it
looks like and that's the case for each
of these three
uh different patient cases so our result
in fact had um approximately 0.9 percent
0.9 sensitivity for a false detection
rate of around
0.2 so wait a minute these are
three different probabilistic graphical
models you should be asking yourself can
deep learning solve everything
so we actually did develop deep learning
algorithms for all
three of these tasks um the new and
enlarging p2 lesion and gout enhancing
lesion
deep learning models were the first ones
to to enter the field but
i'll just tell you for a minute um about
the t2 lesion model for a second
so um we developed this framework it's
just an adaptation of a very popular
model called the 3d unit and this idea
is just to take the images
and to produce a t2 lesion label map
okay so this is a very popular method uh
used for segmentation throughout the
field
and in general uh we um we tested it on
and trained it and tested on a clinical
trial of over a thousand ms patient
brain images
um this trial is multi-center
multi-scanner um
and if you actually look at the results
here this is true positive rate over
fossil detection rate
um in green here you can see in fact the
lesion level results which are actually
pretty good at point two fuss detection
rate or
way up here but if you actually um look
at it according to lesion size
you can see that up here are the medium
and large lesions but down here
is where the small lesions are so in
fact it does not
it's not very sensitive to small lesions
um and that's again a problem in in a
lot of these trials where a lot of the
lesions are quite small
three to ten voxels in size so again um
we found similar issues with the other
two
methods
we do have new deep learning models that
can do better than this
but the point is really um how do we use
deep learning in the clinic if it makes
uh mistakes in general that are
could be kind of critical so if you
actually hand the results to a clinician
um with a series of false positives and
false negatives along with the correct
lesion labels
um this will lead to mistrust of the
system and potentially a reluctance to
adopt the deep learning techniques of
real clinical practice the clinician
might say i can't trust this model
so our thoughts are what if we could
quantify the reliability of the
predictions in the form of an
uncertainty
so predictions are now legion non-lesion
and there's new
uncertain class and the idea would be
that the clinician could then review
um these uncertain uh results um
kind of similar to you know sort of a
junior clinician would refer to a senior
when they are uncertain about a decision
for a challenging case so
um our thoughts are that uncertainty
could therefore be part
of the framework so deep learning being
used to accelerate clinical workflows
and not replace them
and so our thoughts are that uncertainty
will actually build trust
with clinicians and so we built
um a framework to basically produce and
analyze different uncertainty measures
in segmenting and detecting focal
pathologies
in this case ms lesions um and
this is some work by uh former student
tanya who's actually an imagina
who's presenting today and she won the
young scientist award in makai for this
work
and our system produces both voxel level
segmentation results and lesion level
detection results
and examines different uncertainty
measures for
both of these tasks so of course if we
would like
the um these uncertainties to and
to be reviewed by the clinicians they
have to trust
the confident predictions so our
uncertainty measures must have the
property that when they're confident
they're correct
but when they're incorrect they have
higher uncertainties
and so how do we ensure that our
uncertainty measure depicts
depicts this property um so some work
that we did
in which we actually um show that this
is sort of the baseline image you can
see that there's one false
positive but if we actually reduce the
uncertainty threshold in other words
we remove um the most uncertain
conjectures um and so this
these actual false positives and false
negatives then become
uncertain that means that when we filter
out these uncertain predictions the
performance on the remaining
certain predictions should increase
which is what we showed
so let's just talk for the remaining
amount of time on some deep learning
methods that we're working on some
current work and challenges and
opportunities
so as dr arnold discussed we are
working quite hard on predicting
future disease activity from baseline
mri
and so this is some work um that we
presented
two years ago we presented the first
deep learning framework for activity
prediction
from baseline mri and the actual lesion
label so basically the output is
are there any new uh will there be any
new
enlarging t2 lesion labels or gad
lesions a year out
from baseline and so um
what we found is if we just gave the
system baseline mri
we actually do um pretty much the same
as random but with the introduction
of t2 lesions at baseline we actually
did
quite well and so if we provide those
labels at baseline
we can do we can do pretty well in
predicting activity
um so the the interesting thing is if
you actually look
qualitatively at the results here are
the images of patients
um at baseline and this is them in a
year or two later so you can actually
see here
the patients that are inactive and
active
um are written out here so these are
four different patients so you can see
that um
patients here have no new lesional
activity
yet they have a high g2 lesion label uh
load which means they have a lot of
lesions but there aren't a lot of
there's no change in terms of their
disease
activity in the mri and here's an
example of patients which actually have
new and enlarging lesions
and this patient doesn't even have very
high lesion load of baseline
so the system is picking up something
about the lesions of baseline which are
predictive of the future
but what if you don't have manually
labeled lesion
labels available to you so we used our
uh what we found is we took our baseline
images and we used our deep learning
model to actually
predict the t2 lesion labels and then
take
the mri and the predicted or inferred
labels and then predicted
activity and here we found that we can
see here in green that we did have a
slight reduction
in the um area under the curve in the
performance but it still did really well
so you can use that network for that
we also built um the first sort of
preliminary end-to-end deep learning
model
to predict ms disease progression within
one year of baseline based on imaging
at baseline alone so you provide
everything at baseline all the images
any labels you have
and the network produced a binary output
whether
this patient will have um disease
progression in the future in terms of
disability
um and so these are kind of preliminary
results which were
uh presented at medinar absent middle
and
um this is a results on a trial from two
different um
relapsing remitting trials on the
placebo arms and you can see
um basically it's a four-fold validation
the area under the curve is around point
seven which is
um starting to be uh pretty good and
this is um some work that we're
expanding and we're working quite hard
on right now
much more importantly as well we also
have the uncertainty in the output so we
provide an uncertainty measure that can
be used to assess the confidence in the
decision
so the clinician gets an output for
example this patient won't progress
and the degree of confidence in that
assertion so the computers
they would the clinician could then say
okay the computer is certain this
patient won't progress
um and so maybe i will not give it for
example and
the high risk medication
um so then that's the question a really
open and important question of how does
the deep learning model make the
decisions
uh that it makes so the context of the
problem of interpretability
so two years ago at a mikkai conference
dr mcginty the chair of the american
college of radiology
um asked the question and her keynote
uh basically presented to the field this
the challenge and the challenge
that they are saying to radiologists
embracing ai in practice
is that they don't really understand how
ai arrives at a particular conclusion
and so one of the things that we're very
interested in is when the machine
learning method is confident about a
prediction
what is the network looking at and so
our goal is to
to create new mri based biomarkers for
disease progression this will help us
understand the disease course better
and hopefully improve the efficiency of
early phase clinical trials because it
allows us to potentially you know have
enrichment based on these markers or use
them as drought
drug outcome markers so current work
that we're
interested in is uh predicting
patient-specific disease course
predicting the treatment effect on
individual patients
um trying to determine responders and
these problems lead to many open machine
learning
uh challenges which is for example how
do we
build a spatiotemporal model of the
disease course
how do we merge clinical information and
medical imaging to get better
predictions
and in fact how do we merge information
from different clinical trials
altogether
so this is something that we're working
on
so now i'm going to hand over the
platform to
uh raghav a phd student in our group who
will talk about brain tumor segmentation
modeling and propagating uncertainties
and deep learning models
this is in collaboration with synaptive
medical synaptive medical
is a canadian based company based in
toronto
which builds neurosurgical imaging
platforms uh used by hospitals
throughout north america
for surgical planning so
um over to you rugged thank you
just give me a minute
and yep so you can see my screen right
um okay so as professor arbel said that
i'm going to talk about modeling and
proper getting uncertainties in machine
learning models
for patients with brain tumors so
let's dive directly into the problem so
brain tumor segmentation is
clinical really important problem
because it can be used for like multiple
different tasks like diagnosis and
staging of tumor human classification
outcome prediction or surgical planning
uh so generally
there are various uh types of tumor
in particularly for this talk i'm just
going to talk about gliomas or
glioblastomas
so in that normally a brain tumor
structure is subdivided into for the
substructures like edema tumor core and
enhancement
so edema is basically the swelling
enhancement is basically
the active part of the tumor and there
are various
different modalities which are used for
uh
detecting or segmenting this tumor uh
substructures like
flare t2 d1 and t1 post contrast
t1 post contrast is normally used for
detecting the active tumor or like the
enhancing tumor
in that you inject patient with a
molasse and it basically gives you where
the tumor is active or with enhancement
so deep as thou mentioned that like
nowadays everyone is working on deep
learning and deep learning models
have been giving good good performance
so deep learning model based
uh methods have been giving like uh out
performing tradition methods on amika
brought
segmentation sub challenge consistently
from last four years
and there has been various kind of
models which are
which are
developed for this so i'm going to
further like
wait just to give me a minute okay but
this uh
say that this deep learning models have
not been like integrated into regional
clinical practice
so why is that as tall mentioned that it
has to do with the problem
at hand and with the kind of output
which you get from the deep learning
model
so what is the problem at hand so the
problem of segmentation is really hard
because of the shape size variability of
the tumor
etc the data is really noisy you can
have like a
patient motion uh noise requisition etc
and also deep learning models make
mistakes so normally deep learning
models if it gives a deterministic
output it can like to distrust by
clinicians
like if there are a really easy part of
the brain tumor which
deep learning model has made mistakes
and clinicians looks at it
then it will say that oh deep learning
model has not been able to pick up this
easy
part of the tumor itself so it means
that deploying model is not doing
good and i won't be able to trust the
model so it leads to distress by
clinicians and
in turn it will lead to resistance of
them in
including deep learning models into a
workflow
so how do we do that as professor erbil
mentioned that
we do that by defining something known
as an uncertainty where model can say
that
okay i'm not sure about what my
prediction is and in that case we can
ask the clinician to review that and in
that case if we look at
the most uncertain areas and ask
attention to review and for the most
certain areas if the network is right
then clinicians will trust it more and
can integrate it into the clinical
workflow
so how do we get this uncertainty so
there has been various methods for
estimating uncertainty recently i'm just
going to talk about a monte carlo
dropout based method
in which you normally have a neural
network consuming a unit
you train the unit and you have a
dropout
which is a regularization which is
normally used for training but you
also use it at testing which allows you
to get multiple samples
of the same input and you get multiple
outputs and then you can basically
estimate the mean segmentation and the
uncertainty associated with it
this uncertainty can be of different
types like
standard deviation entropy mutual
information etc
and as i said that we want to make sure
that when we evaluate this uncertainty
that the
most confident predictions are correct
and the incorrect prediction are
having a higher uncertainty because that
will lead to better
trust by the clinicians so
how do we do that so we do that by
filtering out the most uncertain
predictions
uh and and evaluate the performance
and the remaining one so what do i mean
by that so let's take the example of
this brain tumor test so because it's a
segmentation task we are just going to
talk about dice
but if it is a classification task we
can talk about an accuracy
so in segmentation what we expect is
that once we
start thresholding out the most
uncertain prediction
what do i mean by uh thresholding up is
that when you threshold up you don't
consider it for the calculation of the
metric
of interest here so in this dice you
don't calculate
the dice for the thresholded one but you
calculate that for the remaining one
so what we expect is that once you
threshold more and more uncertain pixel
the remaining one will be certain pixels
so in that case you will expect the
metric of
metric of interest here dice to improve
so in this way we can evaluate and we
can make sure that
our deep learning models are producing
good results
and we organize the uncertainty
quantification challenge with broads in
love since last two years
if you are interested you can please
have a look at it
uh so another question that apart from
just asking clinicians to give you the
most uncertain prediction how else can
we use it
so in a normally in a medical imaging
pipeline like a brain tumor segmentation
there are like cascade
cascaded prediction tasks uh which
are done before doing the task of the
interest so let's take an example of
tumor segmentation
so first you have multiple modalities so
you do a multi-modal registration
then you do a skull stripping then you
do an intensity normalization
and at the end then you do a tumor
segmentation which in turn can be used
for a
diagnosis purpose so here there are like
four or five tasks before the task of
interest
and each one is presetting by a
n number of tasks so deep learning model
have been introduced for
all these tasks and if we take the
deterministic deep learning model and
if a model is making mistake any one of
the previous tasks
the errors will propagate towards the
downstream task and it can accumulate so
in that case uh
the down syntax can be like hindered in
a really bad way so
what do we do that to solve this so the
hypothesis is that instead of just
propagating
deterministic inference results from
learning models we propagate predictions
and
uncertainties so as i said that you can
use a
any bayesian deep learning model to get
the uncertainties you propagate to do
the downstream task
so this is just a general
so i'm going to talk mainly about brain
tumor segmentation and synthesis
here and this is just a general
segmentation network which performed
really good
but as i said that for brain tumor
segmentation you have multiple
modalities like four different
modalities t1
t2 flare and d1c
but as i mentioned previously that due
to clinical
in the clinical practice due to
different reasons it you might not have
access to the all four different
modalities available so in
that case what we do we try to
synthesize the fourth missing modality
or one of the missing modalities
you using the other available so how it
can be useful it can be useful in
assisting the clinicians in terms of
assessment
also it can be useful for improving the
segmentation so
we developed a deep learning model named
rsnet
i won't go into detail of that so in
that you have
three different modalities and you try
to synthesize the fourth one
so this is a three two one synthesis you
have t1 t2 and t1 t1c
and you try to synthesize the flare one
similar way you have all
other three and try to synthesis t1 t2
or t1c
so the first row represents the real mr
and the second one represents the
synthesis so here you can see that for
flare t1 and t2 we are getting a
good enough synthesis and it looks
uh somewhat close to the real
mr images but if you look at t1c we can
see that
the enhancing part is not good and we
don't expect the enhancing part to be
really good when you are trying to
synthesize the t1c because as i had
mentioned
it requires another contrast agent to be
injected in the patient
to acquire t1c and which is not present
in t1 or
t1 t2 are flat but we can see that
network is making mistakes so it would
be nice to convey these mistakes to the
clinician and
can be used for further downstream task
so as we did previously we use a
multicolored dropout to
get mean and standard deviation which is
basically the mean synthesis and the
standard deviation
uh so we can see here that
as in this one that when we synthesize
the t1c and flare
we can see that network is not
performing really good
for t1c but it is also uncertain about
that so if you if you communicate it
with the clinicians or with the down
syndromes it should be useful
similarly for flare that we can see that
there is a hyperintensity near this
in this part but it is uncertain about
it
so how do we do use it for the
downstream task as i said that you just
get the inference and uncertainty
associated with the
output and then you probably do the
downscript task so here the dancing
tasks of interest is a
multi-class tumor segmentation so for
that we just propagate
synthesized mr and it's uncertainty
associated with
all the three other available modalities
and try to get the tumor segmentation
so uh we did this for t1 and t1c
synthesis and fluid synthesis because as
we looked previously that
those were the toughest modality to
synthesize so here
the first two represent the t1c
synthesis results and the last
row represents the flare synthesis and
we can see that uh from the first first
row is the ground
first column is the ground truth second
column is the synthesis as
mr and the third column is the
segmentation when you just use the
synthesizer
so here you can see in the first row
that you expect here yellow is the
enhancing tumor and you can expect you
can see that
synth in the synthesized mr uh
enhancement is not properly synthesized
but if when
because of that when you do the
segmentation with that you can see that
instead of getting it as an enhancing
tumor it is detected
as a non-enhancing core but when you
look at the synthesis uncertainty
associated with that
you can see that uncertainty is higher
so when you propagate both synthesis
mr and synthesis uncertainty network is
able to correct its mistakes and able to
give you a better performance and you
can see that by
looking at the results that enhancing
tumor is better segmented in the first
row
similarly in the last row you can see
that for the flare synthesis
uh in the synthesized mr there is an
enhancing
enhancement inside the ventricles but
normally it is not there because of
normal it should not be there because
there is no enhancement within the
ventricles now if you look at the
synthetic segmentation with only the
synthesis mr you can see that there is
an edema inside the ventricles
now when you look at the synthesis
uncertainty you can see that
whenever there is an uh hyper intensity
inside the ventricles
it is also uncertain so when you use
both
synthesized mrn synthesis uncertainty
you are able to correct the mystics and
the network is able to get better
performance and there is no edema
segmented inside that
so in terms of qualitative results
evaluated using dice and we can see that
we get a better performance when you
have
uncertainties so i will
allow professor abel to conclude this
session
and i'll give mike back to her
okay thank you very much um raghav so
just in conclusion um i just wanted to
say machine learning and specifically
deep learning has enormous potential to
revolutionize medicine and health care
um you know we have the opportunity to
develop new machine learning methods we
have a lot of
open heart problems i think the main
theme of what we were saying today
is uncertainties need to be addressed
and not swept under the rug
so either we can we need to model the
uncertainties in the problem
uh and that would indeed improve
performance um
communicate the uncertainties to the
clinicians which we feel would increase
trust and and help integrate the methods
into the clinical workflow
and propagating uncertainties across the
task would indeed
um be very helpful uh both as have
showed to improve performance
but also um to avoid the accumulation of
errors in general
um i think the theme today generally is
in in line with
our messages is that for clinical impact
you need
um as we develop our machine learning
methods we need synergy with clinicians
and the end users
it's very important so that we can
design our methods to be doing something
that would be useful in the clinic and
for clinical trials as well
and it's very important to tie the
methods themselves and the metrics of
success
to the real clinical objectives
and i just one more slide just wanted to
thank all of our sponsors
and to all of you for your attention
um so um
rug of i guess um we had a
couple of questions um
no open questions so
there was a question which uh dr arnold
answered
so you can see it there um there was
another
question about um monte carlo dropout
so raghav maybe you would like to answer
that
the question is where to put um
dropout in a network do we put in every
layer input layer is there a better
place to put dropout in the network
and we we know that this is an area of
research and there's different thoughts
about this
um and what benefit does dropout have on
network performance anyway
uh yeah so there has been a paper
from yaringal who basically developed
the
monte carlo transparent ways method uh
the paper is known as concatra
concrete dropout so in that what they
try to do is they try to address these
problems of where to put the drop
out and what should be the
uh what should be the
uh what should be the like probability
of dropping out the networks uh like
neurons and etc uh so they tried to
learn that so their conclusion was that
uh
initial layers if you have dropout that
won't be too much useful compared to the
last layers if it is a classification
network
because glass layers are the dense
layers which basically does your
uh basically defines the boundary linear
boundary between two different classes
and initial layers are the feature
extraction layers but
uh it's still an open problem in terms
of where to put and how to put
so if you are not using concrete dropout
and you're trying to manually tune it
then
it should be tuned in any another way
for any another parameter like a deep
learning model like
you try to tune the learning rate
similarly you have to tune the
dropout rate i hope this answers the
question
well i guess the second part was um why
is it
a good idea to use dropout for network
performance anyway
so i mean like i guess my
so so dropout is just a uh one kind of a
regularization right
so basically regularize or the
regularize your search space
of the number of kind of ways your
network can take
so it does that and when you take a
during the testing you take the
multi-color dropout it basically
gives you multiple samples and you
basically accumulate the samples and not
just do an approximation of the samples
when you do a test
um yeah um i think we don't have any
more
questions so um thank you everyone for
your attention
and um and thank you to my uh
colleagues who spoke today with and for
the organizers for inviting